my ancestor would often say
[Music]
only the most broken people can be great
leaders
introducing name one was really an
opportunity to introduce another
Sovereign ruler of a group of people he
shows up representing talocon he's
coming for the surface World in Marvel
publishing Neymar was one of the first
superheroes frankly they called him
the feather serpent God Namor loves his
people and he's gonna protect them
because to be a ruler you have to serve
the people
that's a deep meaning for me is part of
my personal Heritage as a Mexican as
inhabitant of mesoamerica finally I
could find a more powerful
representation of my culture with
dignity and respect I cannot wait for
everyone to see talukan I'm excited
about how we're gonna see the world come
alive both nations want the same thing
which is to preserve and to protect
their people but they're willing to go
by different ways I need I need to know
before
Namor is very much concern with what he
needs and what he wants this delicate
dance between the two of them I get
chills just thinking about it
my enemies call me no more
foreign